should be live here.
Hello. Let me get the title set and
stuff.
Uh software and game dev. Where is it?
Cool. Looking a little scruffy today. I
need a haircut and a shave.
That's okay.
Let me switch the
Can I switch the camera over?
Yes, I can.
Okay, so we're going to do some net hack
at the moment. Um or actually in a few
minutes at least. I have to clean one
last thing up from this bit of work.
is better.
0968 live
plus clip.
There is a double counting effect.
Cool. Uh,
how do I want to handle this?
Hello. Um, Finn, not quite just yet.
I need to merge your PR,
I'm trying to think how I want to handle
this because I want to do net hack stuff
now. It's just in a really weird state.
Let's get your PR merged upstream first,
maybe.
Oops. This is the wrong browser, isn't
it? No, that's fine.
Hey, Liberty.
Yeah, I'm not going to take a giant copy
like this.
What the hell? And then there's another
Oh, this is [ __ ]
Hang on. If this all looks out, I'm just
banning this dude.
Okay.
Obviously, we're not merging random crap
from this.
Uh, where's my net hack PR?
Is a bit cleaner. Oh, wait. I thought I
had a Net Hack PR open. No.
The PR also has
huh? Is it this one?
Can I merge this yet?
Your is fine. Don't worry about viz. So
I can merge this. Yeah,
And obviously we will uh we'll
eventually try to get this out of here.
Fine. Cool.
Thank you, Finn.
Work from the fin turn.
Let's get some net hack. I really really
want to get some net going in here.
depth config is
in net hack folder. Okay. So you gave me
default score I guess.
do I need a new net hack build or
something with Easy
We do need to figure out um at some
point, Finn, like how tied is Python to
the NLE that you're actually using? Can
we just easily delete Python from um the
NLE dep? Isn't it just C?
No, Python probably delete. Yeah, that's
nice.
Python is just straight cancer. Like it
just goes as soon as you have a little
bit of Python, you get Python
everywhere.
25 minutes. Eh,
holy. Wait, only 11% M time.
Interesting.
I guess we'll leave this up here.
like this.
Mask run.
It's still pretty slow.
This is just like the config being slow
though, man.
not waiting this long for this. Let's
let me try something real quick.
So, we need
256 agents times
It's still 24 minutes. Okay.
Oh, that's bad.
I did ask for a faster config if I
recall.
We definitely want a like an HGPU config
for this.
Um, it's already two. Like I'm doing a
two hour stream right now.
Maybe a little bit over two hours.
Interesting.
We still have algo shenanigans going on
here
off last week of workers. Yeah,
of course. Yeah, I think that just like
once you do a good sweep basically, you
have to constrain the sweep so it
doesn't spawn a ton of MS and it only
uses like eight cores or whatever,
right? Because you need to have it be
scalable.
Um, so ideally you want to try to like
try to do something efficient with
relatively few M's and a relatively
small mini batch. 8K at the very max.
4096 would probably be better even. And
then what you want to do, right, is then
you just run the HPU version, which will
essentially get you 8x the batch size
and 8x the mini batch size and otherwise
be identical.
And then that should get like some
ridiculously fast training. That's how
we can do stuff in the billions.
And we'll see whether this setup I have
on my current branch is any
more than an ish
force 40 I would say max. So like in the
sweep settings probably you want to cap
it out at like 4096ish.
Uh this is not an exact science yet by
the way Finn because like the way that
our multiGP works right is you just get
8x batch and 8x mini batch and 8x ends.
So I mean technically the best thing
would be to sweep at that scale but you
can't really do that. And also like the
hardware perf will scale differently.
So you kind of just want to assume like
hey they're going to be diminishing
returns to scaling batch and mini batch
size. So if we find a reasonably
hardware efficient single GPU config at
lower batches then it should be much
better if we can scale that with
multiGPU.
Yeah, this is this whole thing I've been
working on with off Paul's very screw.
Once you've made an N or two, what would
you recommend?
Because source code still feels scary.
you probably want to do a midsize
project is my guess.
Like you want to do a larger end. Um the
Craftax port was an example of that.
Terraform is an example of that. Uh even
something like 2048 that ended up
actually being an incredibly useful
environment.
So you can do larger end stuff. If you
want to get into research side stuff,
you can do that. But note that there's a
big jump uh to getting into research.
That's when things get like I bang my
head against stuff that should work for
days just to find that like literally
top 10 best known papers in the field
don't work as you'd expect them to.
So
we do we generally definitely need more
m if you want some examples right the
craft tech stuff that's going on now
there are a few people working on things
around that that's super useful we're
going to directly use that end once it's
fast and simpler uh for research
uh's runescape stuff is going to be
really awesome set of ends John also has
the fight caves ends those are going to
be super useful once they're ready um
we have uh there was PR opened as well
for like a thing in neural MMO 3 that
might make that much better. MMO is
still or rather MOA is still relatively
open in terms of it being story and
needing fixes, but I I don't want
anybody destroying the code of that
either. Uh what else we have?
Definitely we need selfplay M at the
moment. A larger project at the moment
that I don't know if I trust a newish
contributor to do, but something that I
w I am thinking about now. We kind of
need a new breakout in the sense that
like breakout used to be the thing that
we ran in 30 seconds that was a pretty
good test for us. Breakout is now solved
in under a second and like basically
anything we do will solve it. So it's no
longer a hard enough test and our next
best stuff like maze and whatnot. Um
we're still looking at like several
minutes and it's pretty limited. like
we'd want an end that tests more
different types of challenges in RL.
The design of that would have to be very
intentional and the difficulty would
have to be well calibrated to be
something where we can like get a
version of it that we can speedrun
starting at like a minute, let's say,
and then try to get that down to 10
seconds over the next few releases.
But those specs are going to be
inherently pretty vague because that's
going to take some fiddling.
Yeah, there's still a lot of low
hanging. I mean, it's just it's not even
that. Yeah, port NES. Yeah, there's lots
of things. Um, there's lots of
lowhanging fruit because basically all
of the RLE is all the RLED is so bad and
screwy and the ends are so slow, right?
I mean, even porting stuff, right? Even
porting existing stuff is pretty nice.
like just getting us a binding to
procgen and then trying to get our conf
policy stack on procgen to actually be a
reasonable throughput. Like that's
something that somebody with a medium
amount of experience could do. I think
FBR reimplemented Doom, but literally
the the actual Doom game has bindings um
that can get up to like a couple hundred
kps. So like there is pixel stuff that
can be done if you want to do pixel
stuff though it's not super super fast.
I think procgen has state come to think
of it. So you can probably do procgen
from state as well and have that even be
way faster. Um really there's a huge
huge amount of stuff we that could be
done at this moment. Doesn't need much
compute either.
I would imagine that with puffer with
like a decent p would just merk procgen
from state.
Okay, we're learning. We're learning.
We're learning. Look at this. Depth 10,
depth 15.
any research. We're going to give this
like two scroll wheel turns.
Oh, Ray is awesome.
100k SPS. It was considered fast. Some
of the logs don't fit on the dash. Yeah.
So, we intentionally do that to like I
intentionally cap the logs like this to
discourage people from logging a million
things.
um just to be a little bit more
intentional about what data you are
actually tracking.
Chess isn't good yet. Yeah, there's a
lot of stuff with chess. There's
probably still some room for
architecture stuff.
I don't know if eventually there will be
some sort of attention based mechanism
that like fixes our con nightmares.
Probably not.
I'm going to have to actually go through
at some point. I want to just get this
policy trained though. I don't want to
derail myself. So, we're going to get
this policy trained in the next 10
minutes and then we're basically going
to play with this and tweak some things.
I like that the end here is at 5%.
That's nice. But I think that yeah,
Finn, if you swept this thing on um
synchronous and then you converted it to
async, for instance, it's going to push
it too far in that direction, like it's
going to overly crank the policy because
it thinks the ENV is very very slow.
Same with search 20. So that'll shift
optimal hypers quite a bit.
bruh. I think I'd be like four or 600
ELO.
I am awful at everything.
Non. Okay. Can I read this out loud,
Tier? Jess, I don't see anything
private.
Uh, I think async is good from what I've
seen. Finn,
non- degenerate shop use
Honestly, like I think we're we're
encouraging the shop too much. It needs
to get the chance to like use it a
couple times and buy stuff, but then
like
it should mostly end up being able to
get uh to learn this first like by
getting AC or getting other stuff.
Identification is the ma the massive
massive one that's really tough cuz this
one is just straight up like human need
to be told what to do.
replacing randomized glyphs with their
true griff glyphs in the obs
when identified.
Bunch of glyphs for different random
item names is wasteful.
A single this is unknown glyph per item.
41 of random scrolls.
Uh you could actually make the obs
massively faster if you do that as well.
I don't think that that helps with uh
identification, but that is a speed
improvement if we can't identify
buck identification.
Never used it. Needs rewards. Yeah. So,
it doesn't
The thing I don't get with this Finn is
like, let's say that you don't know how
to buck test. Do you not just like equip
whatever is cursed and then just hope
you can pray it off later?
Rings and amulets not used at all
are not used at all. Yeah. So like
you're literally not using the strongest
equipment in the game.
Oh, here's a fun idea, Finn. The game
knows what all the items are internally,
right?
Like the game knows all the items
internally, right?
Could we do something where we like
cheat it by letting it see some of the
true items during training in order for
it to like get a sense of like, you
know, if you actually know what the item
is, how useful it is. Maybe we could get
it to ID stuff based on that.
Planning to try that.
Well, it's a good news when you
anticipate the things that I suggest.
That means you're learning a lot.
market worket hack helpful for my own
env uh it's not like a market chest it's
like a game shop where you have you just
go they're items on the ground and you
can pick them up in the shop and then
you can hit P to pay for them
as curriculum yeah that's what I'm
saying Finn now I I don't think that
there's an obvious link for like I know
the ID of some items to I will learn how
to ID items.
Though I suppose
if it sees how useful the rings are when
it knows what the rings can do, maybe
maybe that leads it to like, oh, when I
don't have a ring, I can ID it. But
that's kind of a stretch.
That's kind of too high level logicy.
We might also just be scaffolding too
much. I'm trying to think like
why don't here I have four minutes. Why
don't we do
Spell of identify.
Sitting on a throne.
cheat.
Okay. Um,
one idea for cheating Finn, if we wanted
to let it cheat just a very small
amount, would be to just tell it what is
the scroll of identification and see if
we can get it to use like to get and use
those. Maybe.
It is still the case though that a lot
of the time you can kind of just put
stuff on
stuff
knowledge graph approach.
You definitely don't need that crap for
Super Mario first of all. There are
other places where it's like maybe but
probably overkill
would be cool. Yeah, I think it's worth.
So, I don't think that this is useful
for long-term progress and I really
don't want to get you here. I Let me Can
I Let me frame it for you out, Finn.
Okay. I don't want you to get bogged
down by like doing a bunch of reward
scaffolding and hacky curriculum crap
with this uh with Net Hack. I don't
think that's useful. like making sane
observation and actions that's useful.
Okay. Um
bunch of hacky like scaffolding not as
useful. Now what I do think that that is
useful for though is like let's say that
you tell it what a scroll of
identification is. Okay. And give it
like an identify reward or whatever,
right?
and uh then it just like massively gets
better and like merks Medusa or
something. Okay, then you know that if
the policy can learn this one thing,
then everything else is solved. So you
basically just have a really tough
exploration problem where it's like um
having to have a person do like figure
this out on their own without reading
the wiki and if the thing were written
in braille, right?
And then you can basically decide
whether you think it is a reasonable
thing for them to figure this out or
whether this is external knowledge. In
which case instead of trying to gently
scaffold it towards that solution, you
just give it the piece of information
that it needs like however hacky that
may be because it's like look obviously
this is not learnable. Tabularasa
players can't figure this out on their
own. they have to be told it outside of
the game uh or inside of the game by
reading the text, you know, that's fine.
I think that that's the way to think of
it.
Also, this this thing kind of sucked,
but I have some local changes, so
at least this will be something to look
at.
I would kind of prefer to look at a
better policy than this, though.
I do also have some local changes. Uh
I've tested masking search doesn't make
stuff screw up.
Do you just have that policy that you
can send me that you like you just
linked?
At least now I have I have the new net
hack stuff locally. I'm very excited to
play with it.
to be native through that work.
Oh yeah, that was a useful contribution.
Thank you.
If you feel you're not getting enough
recognition for that, go ahead and just
PR like added action masking contributed
to this or that to the doc site and I
will merge that.
I'm always happy to add attribution.
box connection being slow. O
supposed to be fast, but it sometimes is
not.
the heck.
That's enough of that.
Wi-Fi weird. Yeah. Okay. Wait. Infin
will send us a thing in a second.
I do honestly need to just boot up a
game where I book it and see what
happens.
Like what happens if you just
Interesting.
Oh, there we go. Thank you.
Unmask run in search that was trained
with these
Why is the policy this big?
Wait, 30.
You got a chunky policy here, my guy.
This 3 4 million params.
How long you been doing RL research for?
Depends how you count.
um at the very
latest since 2018.
So realistically more 17ish or whatever
2017ish
nine years
doing other areas of uh ML before that
3.9 million parameters. Yes,
obviously Finn, I'm going to need the
the model size params from you, right?
I need to know the model size
unless uh
encoded somehow.
I don't know the model dims, man. Like
that. Like I need the the number of
layers in the hidden size.
Obviously, I'm going to take the time to
make sure the full demo is is good. This
is just one off.
Model dim's already fine. It can't
possibly be fine cuz it had a 1.9 mil
parameter.
Oh, maybe from the score config it was
depth config was 1.9 mil.
That's what you sent.
Not the the model that you sent, but the
config egg.
good job with this. Holy
little spammy, but
We run.
We get some gold.
Boom. Boom.
Unencumbered.
I like our agent the puffer.
Are you sure dims didn't change?
Uh, in this one I think we're this one.
This policy is definitely loaded
correctly or it would just hard fail.
Oh,
It doesn't consider this to be it like
looks spammy because of the run key.
And then the hunger thing is really hard
to learn.
So we are at delve level four.
And is this level one? We're level one I
think still, right?
What are we going to do about this? Huh?
That was probably a search.
It's like, yo,
what is this? All right, auto pickup is
fully on.
All right, we found it.
Kill the rat.
Wait, the magenta potion evaporates.
Did we try to drink a potion and go
blind?
Oh, we got a bless spell book of sleep.
That's funny.
valk only
oracle.
We're a little bit spammy. I'm feel like
we're like a little bit spammy.
We avoid that.
We're killing things. We're killing
things. We're not just Elberth rushing.
And this does look like net hack
this game play.
Also, are the rooms just actually can or
did you make the room cyan for the
puffer?
We're going to We're level four.
Blue jelly.
You're beginning to feel hungry. Did we
eat something?
How did we just get rid of hunger?
Growth is tough.
We kill the Roth.
We go around the jelly. Interesting.
We kill this rockpiercer.
You eat the rockpierce. Okay, so it eats
the rockpiercer.
It does eat corpses.
Shouldn't be starving.
Wait, is this up?
What are we doing? We have the down
right there. Are we actually exploring?
we are exploring intentionally here,
right?
eating message getting auto skipped by
macro.
Uh it does show it showed the corpse
like the corpse eating you finished
eating the thing but yeah some stuff is
getting skipped. We just yellow lighted
ourselves. I think
you're getting the munchies.
This orange is gnarly.
Uhoh.
We have a hallucination.
Okay. We got robbed by a nymph.
We're hallucinating.
You missed. Yeah, we're still
hallucinating.
Okay, so it's a straw golem.
We kill this.
Yeah, we're not hacking a little bit.
Love the interview. Thank you.
Every day needs to be net hack day. I
wish.
All right. Can we figure out
um
Ben,
do you see something wrong with the
message here?
I don't know. Is that a
a typical net hack message?
that appears when you eat an apple or
pear
on a Unix system.
Wait, are you [ __ ] me?
Is that actually an Easter egg in the
game?
I had to remove the Mac one. It was
messing up cross machine to
you can't make this stuff up. Holy crap.
That's amazing.
Is it getting rewarded for seeing new
rooms, by the way, or just new levels?
Oh,
we have um
how did we ID the scroll of identify
new depth. It seems a little confused.
Yeah.
I wonder if it's trying to kill the
nymph.
I would be trying to kill this nymph
right now.
It just stole an uncursed scroll of
identify from us. That's a very very
valuable item it took.
But no, we don't know how to do that
sadly.
We just drank potion, didn't we? You
feel better.
I think we just yoloed a potion and got
healed. I'm not positive.
Oh, that's actually awesome because now
we should learn identify then because if
we start with the scroll,
if you start with the scroll, it you
know what it is. So if you start with
identify scrolls, then you know every
single scroll of identify.
But I would agree that just like
combining unknown scrolls, Finn, that
actually might be pretty powerful.
At the very least, it would need a bit
for it.
We are now on depth 13.
And now we're kind of starting to yolo a
little bit.
Can we kill this thing?
Yeah, we can kill a killer bee. We're
not that weak.
That's a cockatress.
Are we dead here?
Wait, we know not to hit the cockatress.
Really? We're level six.
You drop a banded mail. Okay, that's
sad. We are um a monk. We drop banded
mail.
Oh, we're going to get stoned here,
aren't we?
No,
we el cockatress.
You don't feel sleepy. We got sleep
rest.
Do we just elith cockatress? That's
decent, right? Those things are
annoying.
What are we stunned?
Incredibly sick.
We have food.
Oh, okay.
Food poison. Cool.
I don't know what we got it from,
though.
Like what what did we have that got uh
gave us nausea?
You're now more skilled in martial art.
Oh. Um hey Finn, can it level up?
Can it level up? It's unarmed.
It can. Does it do it? Like, is it
scripted or what
And we just get to level 14 and we find
something we're not ready for with
Wait, why do we have 10 You see?
And now we're kind of just getting
swarmed by stuff that we should not be
fighting with 10 AC. I don't know if a
water nymph like did we get all our
armor stolen or something?
And we got hit with a run, a wand of
striking. Lovely.
So, we kind of just got surrounded by
hard stuff.
So
key errors honestly.
So Finn, key error from this, right?
It wasn't completely booking it down
like way before it should. It was
underleveled a little bit, but not that
bad.
The main issue is 10 AC. It literally
had 10 AC.
I didn't fully see,
but
I think that um
I think it just had armor stolen by a
nymph.
Or can a nymph even steal armor you're
wearing? It can steal your weapon,
right? But like, can a nymph steal
something you're holding?
Hang on.
Yes, it can
cuz it charms. Okay, cool. So, we lost
our armor to a nymph.
And then we're on depth 14 or whatever
with 10 AC.
And um already a little bit
underleveled. And that's JG,
right?
what we're going to do. Honestly,
I think that the most productive thing
that I can do right now, as funny as it
is,
Have you ever tried to play like the
agent does, Finn?
What is the alignment of the monk
typically?
What's the what was the alignment? Is it
lawful?
Okay, here's what we're going to do.
Let's just get this keyboard.
What's the show inventory setting?
That's fine. I can just hit I.
That's fine. So,
we're going to play like the agent does.
Uh we don't need to corpses
or rather we're going to play like
restricted. We're not going to make any
highle decisions whatsoever.
Plum flumemed helmet.
Cool.
The live button is covering his eyes.
What?
Oh,
also
your mind oscillates briefly.
Palm of opposite alignment. Lovely.
So, I didn't even know. Yeah, don't do
that.
Well, actually, we can ID things on a
monk, can't we? But we can't do we can
only do it with a scroll of
identification.
I think that's reasonable.
And I think it's reasonable that we just
leave our pet as well, right?
how far can we get while playing net
hack really stupidly is the question.
Oh, we also have um I've never played
monk. How do we use We literally have a
spell of of healing, don't we?
Oh, wait. Thus spell book of protection.
I see. Cool.
protection is policy's favorite cuz it's
easy.
Why do you backstab? Because it's easy.
does a lot of damage.
I'm shortcutting because I think that
it's reasonable for it to just learn to
take everything and then drop crap it
doesn't want. I think that's reasonable.
Um,
I'm trying to not do anything. I don't
think that we could reasonably learn
tabbular roster just by playing around
basically.
Okay. And we are not going to care too
much, by the way, if um about hitting
anything. So, unless we get stopped from
progressing,
I'm going to hit S a couple of times
and then I'm just going to go.
What do we have? We got a tin.
We don't have any armor yet.
I think it's it knows how to throw
things, doesn't it? So, I think we will
use those darts if I need them.
It's 3 p.m. I can definitely get a good
run in if I'm quick. Basically, we're
just going to see how I do compared to
the agent roll out. The heck is this
moat? Oh, yeah. Yeah. Well, we're not
going to again, we're not going to inter
even interact with
We're not even really going to interact.
I can't wear this banded mail.
Bear trap. Lovely.
I'm basically just going to progress at
the uh
the normal
exploration rate.
We're playing that hack.
Oh, Jesus.
Okay,
we learned to spell Albert.
See, that's so annoying with monk,
right? We have an elven myithil coat and
we can't wear it.
I don't think I know about Net Hack.
Wait, what do you mean you don't know
about Net Hack?
It's like one of the most influential
games of all time.
Oh, note that we actually This is not
our dog.
Okay. Um, I can take this cloak
and that's it.
I can take the myith my coat to sell cuz
it does know how to sell things.
Uh,
nope.
That's super annoying though
or dumped.
Lovely.
Uh and then what's this?
Yeah, we're done with this.
Okay,
we're on DL level five so far with a
couple close ones, but nothing like
basically not really getting punished
for playing this way, which is kind of
funny.
We even have a magic marker,
which I'm going to drop even though
that's an awesome item because there's
just no way we would be able to use
that. But let's just even though we have
like we got the awesomest thing ever,
our agent is not going to be able to be
able to use it.
Oops.
I'm confused.
Uh, I shouldn't have gone up and I just
go up and finish exploring.
Iron shoes.
We do not have iron shoes. Perfect. We
are allowed to wear those.
This is one of the major things our
agent did not do was get itself some uh
some footwear. We're going to just not
even bother checking if it is uh cursed
or not.
And we're just going to wear gee
plus zero pair of iron shoes.
What's this hobgoblin trapped in a web?
We do not care about the hobgoblin.
So, what are we on? We're on depth five
with AC2.
I do those. So I think that my
progression so far is significantly
better.
However, whoops.
I don't know whether I'm actually going
to be able to get
as deep as the agent does.
I I would think that just by doing this
when would I expect to get punished for
playing this way?
I mean, not until
we're just going to skip the dwarven
like the the gnomish mines entirely,
right?
Yeah, we're going to dip into Soabon.
Going to pass a few turns here. Don't
want to pass too many, but I need some
heals.
Well, I understand, Finn,
but um that's too many turns to pass.
Passing that many turns should make you
anxious.
Like that's your food timer. If you're
using search 20 to search as well, like
that's too much.
Not going to take the mummy wrapping.
That's too complicated to use.
I don't even know what we killed. Just
some nootes.
Take a food ration. It's uncursed. Yay.
Okay, so the monk actually does start.
I'm kind of seeing why this is
considered easy for the early game.
Like if you start, it really does depend
I think on your starting stuff,
I say we drop the spell books because
unless we're going to identify those, I
think um
I think we'll just stick to our starter
book. And again, we're not trying to
play well. We're trying to play simple
like the agent does.
Okay,
I'm stunned.
Interesting.
Don't want to. Oops.
That is a floating eye.
Rot.
I don't have anything else to throw.
It's annoying.
Well, I floating eyes are kind of off
the uh off the board then for getting
I mean if there's nothing that I can I
could zap something at it. I guess
I have no idea what this does. Let's
just zap.
How is it not dead?
I don't even know what that one just
was, but whatever.
Uh, okay. This is now kind of getting
weird.
Where's our entrance?
There it is.
Jelly. That's fine.
I'm just trying to get a sense of like
how well you can do
playing like the agent does, you know,
with like a little bit of refinement
even.
Oh,
hallucinating. Hallucinating.
Hallucinating.
Okay, we kill the giant ant with
protection up.
Oh jeez. Um,
okay.
I have power at the moment, so I'm fine.
Okay. Zap.
Boom.
A wand of [ __ ] That is amazing.
We can definitely zap wands.
Okay. Oracle level.
This is surprisingly though
it's manageable,
but stuff's pretty deadly. Hey,
Oh, we have remove curse. We don't have
identify.
Well, I mean that's kind of better that
we don't
Okay, here's the floor down. But unlike
the agent, we are going to explore a
little bit more here.
Oh, we can just remove that.
I didn't realize that.
We can pray. Oh, okay. That's it
actually.
Unless there is something.
Oh, there's nothing here that I can see.
And again, we're not going to go crazy
exploring. We're just going to explore a
little bit.
I think we're fine on prayer, right?
the hell. Pony
armor and weapons randomized.
Uh, they're randomized and they scale.
So the reason that we're doing this
right is like basically the agent has
access to a subset of the mechanics if
you think about it just because it's not
reasonable to expect them to to learn
some of the things that essentially
require a lengthy text instruction set
in order to pull off stuff like um you
know go dilute a couple of potions and
then go drop them on the altar to make
holy water and then dip dip your stuff
in the holy water to bless it. Like,
that's not going to happen. Or, oh, you
start with a magic marker. Cool. You can
do that, but now you can also dip your
scrolls in and you can uh write identify
on your scrolls to get the
identification spell. Like, that's not
going to happen, right?
Well, that's Soon, isn't it?
Yeah. So, we can't do anything in SOAD,
but we can do this and we can do this.
That's allowable.
We're going to assume that there's no
way we can solve
uh so
I don't really think we have much use
for um for any of this to be honest with
you.
like all these random potions, right?
If we start with potion of healing,
then we know what it is.
Two mil two trillm.
Yeah.
annoying passive.
Oh.
Uhoh.
Interesting.
Oh, wait. You can't reach the ground.
Lovely.
Okay. So, I can do
protection.
This is going to kill me.
You can't engrave here.
I can zap a wand.
This is the problem with using prayer as
well for uh
I mean, I may as well, right? Just see
what happens.
No, I'm dead.
Well,
that's with ACEG -2 and properly
leveled.
that's basically just because I didn't
identify.
Look, we had a ring of regeneration on
here.
gain ability,
lots of spells
or lots of good scrolls.
How would I have handled this normally?
Well, I wouldn't have left my pet.
Probably
maybe at this level I would have
Owl Bear on level eight is not
particularly unlucky either, is it?
H.
I mean, realistically, the mistake was
[ __ ] around with this treasure room.
or treasure zoo
with a yellow light at the door as well.
I mean, we have to try this one more
time. I'm going to go quick.
What in the heck?
Oh, statue is okay.
Or this.
What do we start with? Healing this
time.
the hell? Just fall to de to level four,
I guess, immediately.
Plate mail. That would be nice to have
if I could uh use that at all.
It's locked.
Don't really have anything to force it
with either.
Realistically, when I got the wands of
digging, I could have just zapped them
and gotten super deep.
Well, this is now annoying because what
am I supposed to do?
Did I miss an entrance? I didn't. Right
And again, I am going quick here
as best as I can.
I'm not exactly a uh a great player.
I know the basics only.
Oh, wait. Can we move this around?
This train strength.
I think this does right.
Not push it too much.
We have 17
Uh, okay.
Take these darts.
We want lots of weak things to kill so
we can get some XP.
long sword.
Can I use that? I don't think I can.
Right. You monk punches things. Or can
you use this?
Yeah, just martial arts. So they are you
supposed to punch things.
Okay, so you cannot
equip any armor or you're just screwed,
which is great.
I actually think that the other thing I
want to do um let's go down at this
point. I'm gonna try the same strat if
this doesn't work probably off stream
with Valk
and see if we would expect it to be
better.
What on earth is that? I don't even know
what the hell.
Stethoscope. That's worthless to us
because we are agent and we don't know
what we're doing.
I know what I'm going to do at the end
of the stream with that thing.
provided I don't get one shot by
something stupid.
I'm also going to start eating.
Uh, I think we'll just eat some of our
food while we still have it
so we can save our prayer for if we need
it in a pinch.
Okay.
A few apples.
Farm. What's the ring? Ring.
Granite ring. Very nice.
Why are there just two of these guys
here?
We have healing. That's nice. Runed
dagger.
Okay.
I'd like a runed dagger.
We can use that to open some chests.
Peaceful monkey.
This Yeah, these are peaceful. Cool.
What? Okay, this is Oracle room.
Uh,
the one on the left and on the right a
little bit.
Okay, we got some of this.
And now we need
So, notice we have not gotten any armor.
We do have a ring that I'm uh attempted
to put on.
We found two long swords, which is
funny, but we can't really uh do much
with those
Okay, this is a floating eye. I think
it's reasonable.
I think it's reasonable
to do that
to kill floating eye with ranged weapon
and eat the uh the corpse. I think that
is
something we can do
that like the agent could figure out in
theory.
Soabon ring and tripe rations.
What's this? Yeah, that's all.
I think that's all we're allowed to get
from Soabon.
I'm tempted to put some of these rings
on.
Do we want the agent to just be putting
on random rings?
Could be something very bad.
I would not just be putting on random
rings.
Um
I think what we what is the play here?
So there's no way we can buck test these
rings.
Could we get a holy water? We can't
remove curse. We like we don't
uncurs scroll of enchant armor.
kind of crazy how um
how far the agent gets just doing crazy
things.
Like I would not expect the agent to get
that far actually now that I've been
playing.
There just so many things that can
randomly kill you.
So, I think we have to decide soon
whether I'm going to put on any random
rings
or if I'm going to wait
put on
everything at once.
I'm on D level 9
and I have not found a single
piece of armor to wear
and I have not been doing great
exploration,
but I have been exploring some stuff.
Haven't been completely doing nothing.
needs to go to the mines to gear it
properly.
You might be right.
I mean, just to get like the monk's not
even needing armor.
It just needs like something, man.
some boots or whatever.
So, I guess if you just miss the mines,
a lot of things can kill you in the
mines as well
to be fair.
I mean, I have a couple of rings I could
wear.
I wonder if it's worth it just on
average if you're like
the hell is this.
That is not a friend.
Stay away from that.
grab boots and pickaxe and then dip. Uh,
yeah, you're right. It could. We did get
a pickaxe. So, to be fair, I'm ending
stream in 10 minutes and um or 15
minutesish.
Where's this elf?
Die.
Should
game plan. I don't know yet.
Get away from that.
want to be anywhere near statues.
Particularly not statues of cockatrices.
Oh jeez.
The cockatress pyrolisk.
I would like to be not near that thing.
Thank you. Leather armor. That would be
amazing if I were not a monk.
Do need some XP.
Growth will be
a little bit of XP.
Lovely potion.
Okay, I got some
nice uh wand.
I forget if those things can just cause
stoning and kill you.
Okay, we're on D level 11, though.
And I mean, that does feel roughly
reasonable so far.
Stuff's getting dangerous for sure.
Like right there, is that an owl bear?
No, that's a peaceful ape.
Okay.
Don't have bananas.
What is this? We're not We're not
repeating the same thing from last time.
Thank you. No, thank you. Goodbye.
Crossbow,
chain mail. This game is just like
trolling me with all the armor. We had a
million different pieces of armor that
we could use on anything other than a
monk. Well, I guess not a wizard either,
huh? But still,
I mean,
that's a pretty feels bad.
Okay. Obviously
uncanny feeling. No thank you.
Oh, look. There is a
God damn it. There's an entrance over
there.
We're not dealing with this [ __ ] are
we?
Yeah, there's a wraith here.
That's a cockatress.
Um
What the [ __ ] How do you dig down with
a pickaxe?
I apply it to the floor. Oh, dummy. I
forgot the key. It's just the um It's
the staircase key.
Down.
Wait,
it's literally my own,
I did mess up. I definitely messed up.
Uh well, we can quaff
Wilar's ghost.
Is this bones files?
Hey Finn, are bones files dis That's on
network, isn't it? Actually,
bones files should beworked only,
right?
I mean, I can definitely get deeper now,
but
still very dumb
cuz now I'm super underleveled from two
wraiths somehow.
So this is bo death to okay
death to bones file
Wait, I rubbed the lamp before and
nothing happened.
How did that happen?
I rubbed this lamp and nothing happened.
If we had a genie,
obviously this we wouldn't be able to um
do anything with this.
No bones in the end. Okay, so we just
died to bones file,
I believe. Yeah, we died to bones file
as well as me not knowing that pickaxe
makes noise
as well as double wraith horseshit. Um
to just like just go down strat without
prep is not
it's not obvious that you can just
steamroll doing that. I will say
um it does make sense to me that you can
get pretty deep on some rollouts getting
lucky,
but there are so many things that can go
wrong.
I also genuinely don't know what the
heck else I would do on a monk.
Let's go check the monk. I was hoping I
would be able to just dig down.
So these So you always know what a
potion of healing is.
That's like moderately useful.
Not getting poison res
on a Valk is very bad,
but it's one of the easier ones to get
early just by knowing what corpses to
eat.
identification plus shops is important
now.
There's really not a basic strat is the
thing that gets you way farther without
identifying a bunch of stuff.
We could try. We could try this stat
with everything I did.
I like I'd like to know if it's
literally just identification though
Just I know this like I've read this
article so many times. I need to just
beat the game at least once.
Just very difficult.
They're down.
No magic resist and no reflection is
rough.
Usually this is
all wish possibly two.
You get the amulet of reflection half
the time from soabon
poison res from corpses
gnomeish mines.
Donate to priest for the AC boost. Yeah,
you definitely want to do That
the leveling thing might not even be
that Bad.
How strong do you need to be to get to
the castle?
there are a lot of things that you want
before you get here.
You definitely want the amulet of
reflection.
You want some MR
hopefully from an early wish.
Decent AC possibly art artifact weapon
actually for sure.
Monk makes that very simple in some
sense, doesn't it?
But I it's time. Um I'm going to call it
for here. Thank you for tuning in,
folks. I'm going to play uh I'm going to
play with this a little bit more, Finn.
For sure.
I'm definitely going to play with this a
little bit more. I also I think that the
main thing I really want to understand
is like
I was thinking, oh well, if the agent is
just doing it that way and it's
consistently getting pretty deep, then I
should just be able to refine the
strategy a little bit and uh do
significantly better. But it you kind of
just can't. You just eventually get
screwed by something.
There probably some other things I can
figure out though with it. And I also I
want to try that strategy with a couple
different characters as well and see if
there's like a smooth form of
progression in. But yeah, thank you
everyone. I will uh see you around. Star
Puffer on GitHub if you're interested in
getting involved. Net hack is the latest
benchmark that we are very interested in
doing better on. Uh we have some other
ones as well.